hello everyone my name is paul and i'm
from canada
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
hello everyone welcome to the langfocus
channel and my name is paul
today we'll be going way back to see how
we're all connected
well not all of us but about half of us
around 46
of the people on earth speak an
indo-european language as their native
language
throughout europe south asia the
americas and beyond
the indo-european language family
contains languages as diverse as
english hindi persian russian armenian
and greek
languages which on the surface may seem
to have nothing in common but they
actually do
all indo-european languages developed
from proto-indo-european
according to the most widely accepted
theory proto-indo-european was spoken
around 6500 years ago
on the eurasian step of eastern ukraine
southern russia and the caucasus
the indo-europeans were the first or
among the first people to domesticate
horses which greatly increased their
ability to travel and migrate
over the following three millennia
indo-european people
migrated far and wide conquering new
lands on horseback and bringing their
language with them
as it developed into different varieties
which eventually grew into different
branches of the indo-european language
family
the indo-europeans first migrated into
europe anatolia and central asia
then later into northern india and iran
as migration continued deeper into
europe and central asia
there's an alternate theory based more
on archaeological evidence that suggests
that the indo-european languages began
in anatolia several thousand years
earlier
and spread with the expansion of
agriculture there are no written records
of proto-indo-european and its early
offshoots so the best we can do is to
theorize and imagine
however they happened to take place
during these migrations
proto-indo-europeans split into numerous
different languages
which would gradually develop into
entire branches of the indo-european
language family those branches are
anatolian
which is now extinct tokarian which is
also extinct
italic and celtic which may share a
common italo-celtic ancestor
armenian and albanian which each consist
of just one language
as far as we know hellenic germanic
balto slavic
which split into the baltic and slavic
branches and indo-iranian which split
into the aaronic and indic branches
all of these branches and their
individual languages have been
developing in different regions with
different influences for thousands of
years so they are now very different
from each other
but through comparative study we can see
that indo-european languages share a
common word stock as well as some
phonetic and
historically speaking some grammatical
tendencies there are a significant
number of cognate words in indo-european
languages
by the way the word cognate comes from
latin kong natus which means born
together
these words were indeed born together in
proto-indo-european
and if we're aware of the sound changes
that have taken place we can identify
cognates
for instance the word meaning bear or
carry
in sanskrit it's bihar in greek it's
per in modern greek this might be
pronounced like an f sound but in
ancient greek it was actually an
aspirated p sound in latin it's
fair in gothic it's bayer in old english
it's
bear they all come from
proto-indo-european
baher and my pronunciation of these
different languages is probably not
perfect but i'm just giving it a shot
myself
i should point out that the
proto-indo-european words are
theoretical reconstructions and that
there's no way of knowing for sure what
they sounded like
but these words here are fairly
recognizable some are a little less
recognizable
in english we have the word work which
comes from old english
in modern greek the word for work is
ergo
which was ergon in ancient greek and in
some texts there was an alternate form
wergon they both stem from the
proto-indo-european word
vergom indo-european languages can be
divided into two classes
the kentu languages and the satum
languages
satum is the word for 100 in avestan an
ancient iranian language
kentum is the word for 100 in latin
these two words illustrate a sound shift
that occurred in indo-european languages
proto-indo-european had a palatalized k
sound that was distinct from the regular
velar k
sound a palatalized consonant sounds
kind of like it's followed by a y
sound like as opposed to k in the satum
languages
this palatalized sound remained a
separate phoneme from
k and it became a sibilant sound like a
sa
or a sho so the proto-indo-european word
for 100
kim tom became shatam in sanskrit
shimtas in lithuanian and in many slavic
languages
it's stol these words have all developed
and diverged quite a bit but if you're
aware of the sound shift from a k
sound to an s sound you can recognize
these cognates more easily
in the kentu languages the two k sounds
merge together
or in the case of the germanic branch
shifted to an h sound
so kymtom became kentum in latin
and hecaton in greek kant in welsh
and hund in old english so let's take a
look at these two words in english
100 and sent we usually think of hundred
as a native germanic word
and sent as a loanword from latin but
these are actually cognates
first let's take away the ending of the
word rid which comes from a suffix
meaning
count or number then let's change the h
back to a k
and now you can kind of see the
resemblance see the resemblance
remember that the c in cent was
originally pronounced like a k
k in latin also remember that d is the
voiced equivalent of t
so you can often see these sounds
alternating in related languages
some core words have been preserved in
many or even all indo-european languages
these include some animals for example
proto-indo-european
equos this means horse you know that
equestrian animal
in latin it's equus in ancient greek it
was
hippos in sanskrit it's ashfah and
in persian it's asp the latin and greek
examples are kentum examples
but in greek it seems that the k sound
assimilated to the p
sound next to it the sanskrit and
persian examples are sotum examples
since you can see that the k sound
became
it also seems that the w sound shifted
to a v sounded sanskrit into a b
sound in persian and those are sound
changes that take place frequently in
various different languages
other frequent cognates include the
numbers from 1 to 10 words referring to
family members
agricultural words and various natural
phenomena
like the words for tree and wood in
proto-indo-european
doru or dreyu in old english treyo
in gothic triyu in ancient greek doru
which actually meant spear in sanskrit
daru
in old church slavonic dorivo in
armenian
zaad this shared vocabulary might be
hard to spot when you're not looking for
it
but when you start to notice the sounds
that commonly alternate in those
cognates for example the voiceless t
and the voice d then cognates start to
be more obvious
indo-european languages have developed
so far from proto-indo-european that
grammatically they are very diverse and
they have many features that other
indo-european languages don't share but
because proto-indo-european was a highly
inflected language
all of its descendants are inflected
languages to some extent
by inflection i mean that words change
form to reflect grammatical functions
like
number person tense mood case
one example is the verb endings we find
in various indo-european languages
in proto-indo-european the reconstructed
singular forms for the verb to bear
are behero or the me the heresy
parity and in sanskrit
in latin fero
in old english
in many languages including english
these inflections have been lost to a
large extent
in modern english we only retained the
third person inflection
he bears or she bears but english still
had the second person inflection until
the early modern english period
so if you read a king james bible you'll
see the sentence
thou bearest record of thyself this is
the second person form
and thou means you cases
proto-indo-european nouns had
inflections for eight grammatical cases
sanskrit maintained all eight cases and
so did the ancient iranian language
avestan
latin retained six cases and old english
had four
modern english nouns do not have case
endings and that's also true for many
other indo-european languages
like most of the romance languages when
languages no longer have case
inflections
the function of nouns is indicated more
by word order and by the use of
prepositions
but many modern indo-european languages
do have numerous cases
like most balto-slavic languages which
have six to eight cases
german and icelandic which have four
cases and modern greek which also has
four
so the connection between the modern
indo-european languages may not be
obvious but when we look back
historically at how those languages have
developed and the different stages of
those languages
we can find more connections the
question of the day
if you speak an indo-european language
did you discover any new connections
between your language and others during
this video
let us know in the comments down below
be sure to follow langfocus on facebook
twitter and instagram and thank you to
all of my
fantastic patreon supporters especially
these wonderful people right here on the
screen
thank you for watching and have a nice
[Music]
day
[Music]
you